[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تتصاعد حده القتال في سوريا حيث اقترب من
مناطق حيويه في العاصمه دمشق مثل المطار
والقصر الرئاسي واشتد كذلك في حمس وحما
سياسيا اكدت روسيا انها لا تستطيع اقناع
الاسد بالتنحي وان الصراع لن يحسم
[موسيقى]
عسكريا
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من زاويتين
الدلالات العسكريه لاقتراب القتال بين
الجيشين النظامي والحر من مناطق حيويه في
العاصمه دمشق والمغزى السياسي لتصريحات
موسكو حيث تبدو متناقضه مع مواقف صدرت
عنها الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
الماضي السلام
عليكم استبعد وزير الخارجيه روسيه سيرجي
لافروف انتصارا عسكريا لاي من طرفي الصراع
في سوريا مؤكدا ان روسيا والصين لا
يمكنهما اقناع الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
بالتنحي يعد هذا الموقف الروسي متعارضا مع
تصريحات لمبعوث الكرملين الى الشرق الاوسط
الاسبوع الماضي قال فيها ان المعارضه قد
تنتصر على الاسد عسكريا تشتد سخونه
المعارك العسكريه على اكثر من
جبهه يشهد هذا الخراب بعنف المعارك
الدائره في بعض الاحياء الدمشقيه مناطق من
العاصمه السوريه باتت مسرحا لمواجهات شرسه
بين مقاتلي الجيشين النظامي والحر وصلت
بحسب اخر الاخبار الوارده من هناك الى
محيط القصر الرئاسي بعد ان حمى وطيسها في
منطقه دمر عند حاجزي جبل قاسيون واللواء
105 بات اذا بوسع الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد ان يشهد عن قرب ربما واحده من اخطر
تبعات النهج الذي اختاره لمجابهه الاحتجاج
المطالبه بتنحيه عن الحكم ما كان في مرحله
ما بعض المظاهر المسلحه التي التت على
نفسها حمايه المتظاهرين العزل تحولت الى
جهد عسكري منظم يشتبك مع الجيش النظامي في
طول سوريا وعرضها قادرا على اصابه بنيه
النظام في مقاتل لعل اكثرها حساسيه المقر
الرئاسي بما يحمله من رمزيه لا تخطئها عين
الحصيف ولعل الاسد المستغرق في الاوضاع
الامنيه المتفاقم تحت حكمه تصله تقارير
عسكريه واعلاميه تتحدث عن سقوط عدد من
معاقل جيشه تحت وطاه هجمات الجيش السوري
الحر اخرها السيطره على الفوج 81 في
المليحه
بغوطة
وهم الممه
بالمدنيين لاعلامه الذي وصف انجازات
المعارضه بفرقع اعلاميه لا قيمه
استراتيجيه لها لن ينتصر احد من طرفي
الصراع قناعه بدت واضحه في اخر تصريحات
لوزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروف
استبعد فيها ان تمارس موسكو اي ضغوط على
الاسد لاجباره على التنحي نافيا ان تكون
بلاده والصين ملاين مفترضين للرئيس السوري
في حال اجبرته تطورات المعارك على التفكير
في الرحيل من بلاده اطروحات كرست جدلا
روسيا امريكيا غربيا محوره مستقبل الوضع
في سوريا ليس احد يدري هل سينتهي بوقف
المحرقه السوريه ام ان التطورات الميدانيه
هي من سينهي فارضه على الجميع مرحله جديده
كليا ومعنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستوديو اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير في
الشؤون العسكريه من موسكو الكاتب والباحث
الاكادي ديمي ليونيد سوكان ومن اسطنبول
سمير نشار عضو الائتلاف الوطني السوري
وعضو الامانه العامه للمجلس الوطني السوري
اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا هنا بالاستديو
باللواء فايز الدويري ما تقييمكم لمجمل
التطورات الان خاصه العسكريه اقصد خاصه في
العاصمه دمشق في الواقع اخ محمد ما يجري
في دمشق هو جزء من كل هناك
تصعيد فوق الجغرافيه السوريه كامله بدءا
من دير الزور الى الرقه الى حلب الى حماء
الى ادلب حتى حمص المحاصره الى درعا ومن
ثم الى دمشق ولكن بما ان السؤال يتمحور
حول دمشق وهي مركز الثقل السياسي ومكان
القياده السياسيه والعسكريه دمشق في
الواقع هي الان محاطه بنطاق يبدا من دوما
في الشمال الشرقي الى ديار العصافير في
الجنوب الغربي وانتهاء بال بالجنوب الغربي
هذا الطوق تقريبا شمه ممسوك الى درجه ما
وتحت سيطره معقوله من قوات الجيش الحر بقي
من خلال الدائره الكامله للاغلاق على على
دمشق بصوره كامله يمكن بحدود 80 الى 90
درجه من اصل 360 درجه اللي هي من منطقه
دوما الى جبل قاسيون عندما تنتقل المعارك
تتجاوز منطقه المزه الى دوما
والى الى بدايه جبل قاسيون هذه لها
دلالاتها في بعدها الميداني وفي البعد
العملياتي والاستراتيجي في البعد الميداني
هناك اخفاقات متتاليه لقوات النظام في
اداره معاركها واقتصر دورها على رد الفعل
اينما تتحرك
القوات المعارضه المسلحه يبدا رد الفعل
ولكن لا يوجد زمام مباداه وهذا يعني في
العلم العسكري فقدان القياده والسيطره وهي
مفاتيح النصر بالمقابل في في البعد
الاستراتيجي اذا تحدثنا عنه اذا اردنا ان
تتحدث عن المعركه المستقبليه لمدينه دمشق
فنحن نتحدث عن المعركه الحاسمه النهائيه
هذه المعركه لا يمكن ان تحسم من قبل
الثوار الا ضمن معطيات اساسيه اهمها تطويق
العاصمه كليا وقطع التواصل مع العمق
الاستراتيجي في منطقه حمص ومرورا الى
اللاذقيه
والقرداتي
واللواء 105 هو تحقيق موطئ قدم لكن هذا
غير كافي ولا بد من التمسك بالارض
وتطويق المنطقه واحتلالها لانه فيها فائده
تعبو توجد العديد من مواقع الاسلحه
الثقيله ذات المديات الناريه البعيده التي
تقصف الغوطه والاحياء الجنوبيه من دمشق
على ذكر موطع القدم سيد سمير نشار في في
اسطنبول اقتراب المعارك من مطار دمشق ومن
القصر الرئاسي حسب بعض المصادر هل له معنى
معين
برايكم اعتقد انه هقلق وهذه المعلومات
التي وصلت الى الحكومه الروسيه هي السبب
في التصريحات التي ادلى بها السيد
بوجدانوف
وانها وانه يتوقع ان النظام السوري ممكن
ان ينهار وان المعارضه ممكن ان تنجح في
اسقاط بشار الاسد عسكريا هذا الموقف الي
نقلته دوائر الاستخ مارات والتي اكدت ان
هناك تحول في موازين القوى العسكري على
الواقع في الارض وخاصه في اهم مدينتين
دمشق وحلب هو مبعث قلق الموقف والتحول ليس
فقط قلق قلق وتحول في الموقف الروسي التي
تخلت عن مطلب بقاء بشار الاسد بالسلطه من
هنا نرى ان اجتماع دبلن الذي جرى بين
السيد لافروف والسيد كلينتون وال الاجتماع
التالي بعد عده ايام بين السيد بوجدانوف
والسيد ويليام بيرنز وكلاهما وكلا
الاجتماعين بحضور السيد الاخضر الابراهيمي
ا يعكس برايي ان هناك تحولا ما سياسي في
الموقف الروسي هو على ذكر الموقف الروسي
اسمح لي فقط سيد نشار الموقف الروسي
سنتناوله بتفصيل اكثر بعد الفاصل كمحور
ثاني في الحلقه بعد اذنك الان على صعيد
الوضع الميداني والامور مترابطه بطبيعه
الحال هل تعتقد بان المعارك في دمشق الان
فعلا معارك مفصليه انجاز
التعبير بالتاكيد بالتاكيد انها معارك
مفصليه وان كانت لا تزال هي معركه طويله
ولكن ادت وتعطي مؤشرات بان النظام حوصر في
دمشق وان النظام مهما طالت مقاومته ولكن
قطعاته وقوات النظام تعاني من حاله تفكك
ومن حاله انهيار في الروح المعنويه وهناك
خشيه من ان تتداعى الحاله لدى اغلب
القطعات العسكريه المحيطه بدمشق وبالتالي
يطرا تحول دراماتيكي بدمشق يؤدي الى
انهيار مفاجئ للنظام بدمشق وهذا مبعث قلق
روسيا في التحول السياسي وسعيها لايجاد
تسويه سياسيه قبل ان يسبق الحل العسكري
التسويه السياسيه من
هناط السياس
ذ لنر
س سكي كيف هي الصوره في موسكو عندما يتعلق
الامر بتقدير وتقييم الوضع العسكري
الميداني خاصه في دمشق هذه
الايام طبعا فيما يتعلق بتطورات الاخيره
على
الساحه على الارض في سوريا من الناحيه
العسكريه فتبعا الموقف الروسي يعكس هذه
التطورات على حتى تعبير والتصريحات التي
ادلى بها قبل اسبوع تقريبا نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي بوغدانوف قائلا بانه
روسيا لا تستبعد الفوز العسكري للمعارضه
وتعترف بانه النظام السوري تفقد سيطرته
تدريجيا في الاراضي السوريه وروسيا لا
تستبعد للاسف هو قال ذلك و يعني شدد على
هذه العباره وللاسف قد تفوز المعارضه
العسكريه على نظام في في سوريا ولكن في
نظر روسيا هذا ليس هو نهايه القضيه ولكن
التغيير المبدئي
وال نوعي في المنطقه
ولكن
هذه النقله النوعيه لا تجيب على السؤال
المحوري ما هو المستقبل السياسي لسوريا
وما هو تقريبا
الافاق سياسيه للوعه وكيفيه الاستقرار
ونهايه الحرب لا تعني ال
الاقامه الاستقرار السياسي في هذه المنطقه
وبالنسبه لروسيا هذا هو اهم من فوز اي طرف
من طرفي النزاع نعم هو على كل تصريحات
بوجدانوف كانت الاسبوع الماضي ولكن ما لفت
الانتباه هذه المره تصريحات جديده لسيرجي
لافروف يقول فيها بان الرئيس السوري لا
يعتزم ولا ينوي الرحيل وان اي تسويه
سياسيه يجب ان تاخذ بعين الاعتبار التنازل
عن اي شروط مسبقه بما في ذلك مطالبه برحيل
الرئيس بشار الاسد هذا تطور جديد سنحاول
ان نغوص فيه اكثر بعد فاصل قصير نرجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا انا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نخصصها للاوضاع في سوريا سواء
الميدانيه في العاصمه او
الموقف الروسي في مما يجري
هناك سيد فايز الدويري تصريحات سيرجي
لافروف في رحله العوده من بروكسل الى الى
موسكو لعدد من الصحفيين بدات وكانها تناقض
ما قاله بوجدانه في الاسبوع الماضي في
تمسك بان بشار الاسد لن
يذهب روسيا غير معنيه بمصيره ان ياتي
اليها ولا حتى الصين وان اي تسويه سياسيه
لا يمكن ان نسقط منها بشار الاسد لانه لا
ينوي ولا يعتزم الرحيل كيف تفهم هذه
التصريحات اي في الواقع اذا عدنا الى
تصريحات لافروف خلال الاشهر الماضيه وقرنا
بتصريحات نائب بوجدانوف نجد انه دائما
هناك تعارض ويعاد اصدار تصريح جديد بان
بوجدانوف لم لم يقصد ذلك ولم يقصد هناك
بعض الاشارات تدل على ان بوجدانوف هو
الصندوق الاسود للرئيس بوتين وهو الاكثر
ولاء وقربا منه وبالتالي هو الذي يملك
الحقيقه اكثر مما يملكها هكذا اشارت بعض
التقارير انما انا اقرا تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه في اكثر من بعد البعد الاول انا
اقرا بها ان كان روسيا تريد ان تقول
للعالم نحن امضينا 20
شهرا في موقف محدد نتحدث عن مصالحه نتحدث
عن اجتماع الاطراف حول طاوله معينه وفي
النهايه طلبكم برحيل الرئيس بشار الاسد
نحن لا نستطيع ان ان نرغم على ذلك
وبالتالي هي تبحث عن اخراج نفسها من
الازمه السوريه وتبحث عن دور مستقبلي لها
مقبول من الثوره السوريه اذا هو يناور في
هذا الكلام من اجل مصالح روسيا على حساب
الدم السوري ولكن هناك عده مقاربات حدثت
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين اخ محمد اولا
اجتماع بوجدانوف مع نائب وزير الدفاع
الامريكي والحديث
الذي رشح عن ذلك على على شكل مبادره اي
مبادره السيد الاخضر الابراهيمي وهي تعتبر
جنيف رقم اثنين وهي تتحدث بصراحه عن
احتمالين الاحتمال الاول سيحمله سيحملها
الاخضر الابراهيمي ان على بشار الاسد ان
اي يساهم في انشاء حكومه انتقاليه ذات
صلاحيات موسعه وبعدها يستقيل مقابل هذا
الاشتراك لديه ال الحصان الدوليه كما حصل
للرئيس علي عبد الله صالح والاحتمال الاخر
اذا رفض ان تكون على صيغه انثار بانه
ستشكل الحكومه بدون مشاركته ولا يحصل على
الحصانه الد الحسان الدوليه اذا هناك
تقاطعات دوليه كثيره ل نربطها مع تصريحات
نائب الرئيس اللي هو السوري فاروق الشرع
والذي لا يمكن ان يتحدث الا بموافقه
الاجهزه الامنيه واجتماع بوتين اردوغان
الذي طرح فيه اردوغان ان على الرئيس
السوري ان يشكل الحكومه ويستقيل خلال
ثلاثه اشهر نعم سيد سوكان هل ه هل هذا
التحليل هو السائد الان في
موسكو هنالك اكثر من راي في موسكو هنالك
تفاوت
في التقييمات والاقاويل
والتصريحات والدراسات وما يكتب وينشر في
وسائل العلامه المرئيه
والمكتوبه هنالك تفاو شاسع في في الاراء
وطبعا هنالك من يتمسك بهذا الرايه الذي
تفضل به الزميل المشارك في هذا الحوار الى
جانب وجود الاراء الاخرى وعلى هذا
الاساس اما بالنسبه لموقف الرسمي الروسي
فانا خلافا لي السيد
الكريم لا ارى تناقض مبدئيا في هذه
التصريحات هذه التصريحات اذا ادلت على شيء
فتدل ان روسيا تتابع الاوضاع في سوريا
وتغير تقييمها على الضو التغييرات في في
في المنطقه نفسها والاعتراف
باحتمال الانتصار العسكري للمعارضه هذا هو
امر الواقع هذا هو تقييم موضوعي واقعي لل
ما يحدث حاليا في سوريا ولكن في نظر روسيا
هذا هو السيناريو ليست
بايجابيات لاي طرف على طرف الاخر لن تؤدي
الى نهايه الحرب بل س تدول على
استمرار النزعه رب ما سيتحول هذا النزاع
من حرب الاهليه الى حرب العصبات او اي
المرحله الاخرى ولكن بدلا من ذلك كان في
ننادر وروسيا بدل المزيد من الجهود لوقف
الاطلاق النار وقف العنف وبادل الجهود
لتنفيذ القرارات التي صدرت عن المؤتمر ال
جنيف في في شهر حزيران الماضي اذا كانت
كافه القوه الدوليه تعمل في هذا الاتجاه
ففي نظر روسيا هذا سيكون افضل بكثير مما
يحدث حاليا في سوريا ولكن الاشارات تبدو
متناقضه كلام لبوج دانف كلام لبوتين كلام
لسيرجي لفلوف سيد نشار هل هذا الكم من
التصريحات هز نوعا ما من تصوركم على عن
طبيعه الموقف الروسي وامكانيه التاثير
فيما يجري في
سوريا السيد بوتين اشار بوضوح انه لم يعد
يهتم بمصير بشار الاسد ولا بنظامه انهم
يفكروا في مرحله ما بعد بشار الاسد هذا
تصريحه بكل وضوح هذا يعكس تحول حقيقي في
الموقف الروسي اليوم الاخضر الابراهيمي
ينتظر في القاهره تحديد موعد من بشار
الاسد وبشار الاسد يتعمد عدم اعطاه موعد
قريب لانه يعرف فحو الرساله التي سوف
ينقلها الاخضر الابراهيمي وهي التي تعرض
عليه خيارات يرفضها يجد فيها صعوبه في
انها سوف تنهي دوره ومن تزيله من المشهد
السياسي في سوريا لا شك ان روسيا لم تعد
متمسكه في بشار الاسد ولذلك بعد تصريحات
يعني عفوا حتى بعد عفوا حتى بعد تصريحات
لفرو التي يقول فيها بانه لا يعتزم ولا
ينوي مش مش فقط لا يعتزم لا ينوي الرحيل
وان وان ايضا هي تسويه سياسيه يجب ان ان
ان تبقي على ان الشرط المسبق الخاص بذهاب
الاسد يجب ان
يسقط انا اعتقد ان هذه التصريحات هي عباره
عن تحسين شروط التفاوض شروط التفاوض سوف
تبدا في دمشق هذه الاشارات التي يرسلها
السيد لافروف انا اعتقد انها لتحسين موقع
بشار الاسد في مفاوضاته مع السيد الاخ
اخضر الابراهيمي انا لا يمكن ان اخذ
تصريحات السيد لافروف على محمل الجد وانسى
تصريحات السيد بوتين الذي هو رئيس
الجمهوريه في روسيا الاتحاديه السيد بوتين
هو من يقرر اولا واخيرا السيد بوتين قال
انه لم يعد مهتم لا بالنظام السوري ولا
بمصير رئيسي ليس المهم اين يذهب بشار
الاسد ولكن الرساله ان بشار الاسد انتهى
دوره اقناعه في التخلي هذا يعتمد على بشار
الاسد ليقرا الموقف بعد تخلي روسيا عنه
وبالتالي ان الصين سوف تتخلى عنه وبالتالي
ربما يكون هناك اعاده تموضع للموقف
الايراني ايضا على من سوف يعتمد بشار
الاسد في بقائه في السلطه في ظل تقهقر
قواته وتفككها في دمشق وفي باقي المحافظات
السوريه هذه ما تقوله جميع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه لنرى ما لنرى ما اذا كان
يعني عفوا لنرى ما اذا كان السيد سوكين
يعتبر فعلا بان تصريحات لافروف هي من باب
تحسين شروط الوضع الخاص ببشار
الاسد انا شخصيا لا اعتك ذلك ليس هنالك اي
مساومه
ا يعني حول الشخصيه بشار الاسد ومستقبله
هو سياسي او كانسان او كرئيس او
كرجل سياسي لا اعتك ذلك روسيا دائما ولا
تزال
والان ب على وجه التحديد وعلى ضوع
التطورات الاخيره تركز على ضروره الايجاد
المخرج الذي يستجيب لمصالح الشعب السوري
ويؤمن المستقبل
المستقر للشعب السوري
ومنطقه بالكامل وفي نظر روسيا كل ال
السيناريوهات
التي تتمثل في ال العنف واستعمال القوه
العسكريه من قبل النظام او قبل المعارضه ا
لن تؤدي الى الاستقرار السياسي في في
سوريا
ولن تدع الحد لل اراقه الدم في سوريا هل
هنالك
من يعتقد جديا انه اذا سقط نظام ففي نفس
اللحظه سينتهي كل الاقتتال والعنف و
والمذابح والمجازر في سوريا هل هنالك من
يمكن يعني يقدم الضمانات لذلك لا لن اعتاق
ذلك وعلى هذا الاساس روسيا حاليا تهتم
اكثر فاكثر بالمستقبل السياسي لسوريا بدلا
من الاهتمام والمساومات
وتحديد الشروط وغيرها لشخصيه الرئيس او
لنظام
وغيرها
المواقف الروسيه كلما زادت كلما ازداد
الغموض وهنا اسهل في نهايه الحلقه اللواء
فايز الدويري اما اذا كان الموقف الروسي
يزداد غموضا وليس وضوحا هناك بعض التقارير
تعقيبا على على ما ذكر الزملاء هناك بعض
التقارير اشارت وتحدث عنها السيد اديب
الشيشكلي بان الرئيس السوري وافق من حيث
المبدا على على الخروج من سوريا ضمن
محددات هذه المحددات قدم قائمه باسم 142 ش
شخصيه يخرجوا معه ويحصلوا على نفس
الضمانات الامنيه منهم 108 من القاده
العسكريين والامني الذين اصدروا اوامر
القتل بحق الشعب السوري اذا هناك في تضارب
في في التقارير وبالتالي هذا التضارب انا
اضعه من باب التمترس حول المرحله
التفاوضيه انه الان يصرح يؤخر القدوم
الابراهيمي يرفض ويصرح لافروف بانه لا
يستطيع الضغط روسيا لا تستطيع الضغط حتى
وان طلبت منه
رو هذا الكلام هذا الكلام يشبه التفاوض
الاسرائيلي الحمساوي في الحرب الاخيره على
غزه الكل يتشدد في مطالبه ليحصل على اكثر
مكتسبات يمكن الحصول عليها وبالتالي
النظام هو مقتنع داخليا بانه ساقط
والمساله مساله وقت ويحاول ان يحقق بعض
المكاسب شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير في العسكريه نشكر ايضا
نشكر ضيفين ايضا من موسكو الكاتب والباحث
الاكاديمي ليونيد سوكان ومن اسطنبول سمير
نشار عضو الائتلاف الوطني السوري وعضو
الامانه العامه للمجلس الوطني السوري
وبهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
غدا باذن الله قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر
جديد استودعكم
الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ا